good afternoon hope that you all have
had a great summer we are here today to
give you some ideas for how to plan a
great rest of your year another year
we're going to start with talking about
science instruction in another
presentation I'll be talking to you
about kind of the philosophy of science
instruction in a classical school but
this portion is going to be talking more
about what does good science instruction
look like in the classroom kind of
keeping some of those philosophical
principles in mind again in a different
presentations but then what does that
look like in practice so before we start
with that let's just talk about kind of
what is the k-12 science scope and
sequence look like in your school in
grades K through 8 most of the sequence
or much of the sequence is based on the
core knowledge sequence which I know
some of you are familiar with but we'll
talk a little bit more about what that
looks like and then the high school
sequence really looks a lot like what
you've what you might find in a regular
public school or private school but it's
about how we teach it that sets us apart
a little bit from other schools so that
looks like a 9th grade biology course
and a 10th grade chemistry course and
then in 11th grade maybe giving students
the option of physics or giving them an
elective course and then in 12th grade
maybe another elective we really highly
recommend four years of science in a
high school and the requirement of
biology and chemistry we'll talk about
where physics kind of fits in but in
many schools that might be a requirement
or it might be an option for students
based on their math ability some of the
electives that students can look forward
to a couple of examples that many of the
Barney charter schools have done are
anatomy and physiology I'm a history of
science course in the 12th grade
zoology astronomy and oftentimes many of
the AP courses in biology chemistry or
physics or another kind of second year
college-level course
so let's focus a little bit more on K
through 8 because in those grade levels
there's a smattering of topics
essentially that's in every single grade
so as you'll see displayed for you
several different topics are taught in
many different grade levels and I've
kind of divided them up by life science
topics kind of chemical physical science
topics and earth science so for example
human biology topics are taught in
nearly every single grade level so as a
3rd grade teacher you don't have this
pressure that you have to teach the
whole human body that year you'll have
some particular human body topics to
focus on and then it will spiral upon
itself in future grade levels you'll
also notice that students are getting
introduced to some really rich content
at an early age so students are learning
about motion and forces for example
through simple machines as early as
second grade now they don't have to
learn about all of the equations in the
math that governs those principles and
that will be revisited again in in
eighth grade so let's talk about the
seven principles essentially that I have
for great instruction in a science class
so things that teachers can be doing to
to deliver a great lesson
these are cultivating wonder and an
appreciation for the natural and
physical world teaching science as a
story requiring the mastery of
vocabulary and processes models laws and
theories and equations that kind of
govern our scientific understanding
incorporating science biographies
requiring clear concise and thorough
explanations of the students performing
demonstrations and conducting labs or
doing other teacher-led activities that
supplement the lessons that you're
already delivering as a teacher and
finally asking excellent questions to
help the students make connections so
we'll spend a little bit of time on each
of those and what I'll do is use a fifth
grade topic
be a little bit in the middle of the
different grade levels to illustrate
some of these principles so that
fifth-grade content I'm going to focus
on our cells so in the fifth grade
students are asked to know and
understand the structure and function of
the many different parts of the cell and
so the first principal cultivating
wonder could be done with elementary
students in a couple of different ways
projecting images or giving students
images of cells and not telling them
that that's a cell giving them an
electron micrograph or an image from
under a microscope and just asking them
what do you think this is and then
through further questioning try to get
students to get to the point of the fact
that it's a cell
maybe it's performing a demonstration
this is a little bit trickier with more
life science topics like the cell but
maybe you're doing a chemical example
such as introducing physical change
versus chemical change and you just mix
up some solutions in front of your
classroom or add pepper to water and
salt to water and ask students to tell
you what happened and maybe give an
explanation of why that was finally
especially Elementary students love just
fun fascinating facts and oftentimes the
grosser the better so you might
introduce cells to students this way did
you know that you have thirty seven
point two trillion cells and each of
those cells has a different job and they
might get really you know think that's
cool or maybe not but then you could say
did you know you lose 30,000 to 40,000
skin cells per day look that's nine
pounds of cells that you lose every
single year how's that for some weight
loss so get them excited about what
they're learning by giving them some
kind of fun fun facts about the world
around them the second idea is to teach
science as a story so when I mentioned
parts of the cell or organelles these
are things like the cytoplasm and the
cell membrane
and the nucleus and the lysosome how
many of you remember learning those in
school how many of you remember them
remember learning them in a very boring
flat way maybe the teacher just said
we're going to talk about the parts of
the cell first we have the cytoplasm
everybody say cytoplasm cytoplasm the
cytoplasm is the gel-like structure that
holds all the organelles together and
then maybe that definition is put on the
board you copy it down and then you move
on and the teacher will say we have
another word that begins with C now we
need to keep these separate this is
called the cell membrane and then you're
given the definition of the cell
membrane but often times for students to
understand especially new words and
topics and science that are unfamiliar
to them it's helpful to teach it as a
story so the organelles inside of a cell
are organized with particular structures
and functions so you might start out
with how and start out explaining to
them how things move throughout the cell
and introduce the parts of the cell that
way so you might start out with
something like the nucleus because the
nucleus is the control center of the
cell and then ask students what do you
think I mean by control center what's a
control center and students will
eventually get to the point that it has
the instructions for what the cell
should do and some students might even
know that that means DNA and so we will
start essentially with what how the cell
knows what it needs to do we'd have an
image maybe projected for them that
points out where the nucleus is located
then we might move on to something like
the ribosome asking students that are
telling students the ribosomes job is to
make proteins
the ribosome looks like on your picture
these small tiny dots that are located
throughout the cell everybody say
ribosome makes proteins and get that
definition kind of squared in their head
then you might ask students to to see
that the ribosomes are also located on
this structure right outside of the
nucleus called the endoplasmic reticulum
which they like to say because it's kind
of fun and so ribosomes are located on
the endoplasmic
particular so if ribosomes make proteins
and the endoplasmic reticulum has
ribosomes on it what do you think the
job of the endoplasmic reticulum is and
they'll get to the fact that it also
makes proteins why do you think it needs
to be very very close to that control
center the nucleus well because the
nucleus needs to tell the endoplasmic
reticulum how many and what type of
proteins to make now that was a very
quick overview and you would spend a lot
more time on that but you could work
with students on essentially making
proteins and then moving on to the other
parts of the cell whose job is
essentially to repackage the proteins
and send them off to different parts so
we're starting at the center of the cell
with the nucleus moving to the
endoplasmic reticulum then going on to
things like the lysosomes and the
vacuoles and the Golgi apparatus which
move those protein packages around and
then out the cell membrane and out the
cell wall and so then students have put
together essentially characters in a
story of how things move throughout the
cell the next concept or principle that
I would emphasize is mastery of
vocabulary and key concepts and
equations inside of a science class so
this is as was mentioned this sequence
is extremely content-rich so for
something like this fifth grade example
you have all of those different weird
funky names of the cell there will also
be some chemical concepts in which
students have to understand some weird
names of things on the periodic table or
understand basic equations or how
something works and so this is done and
I'll talk about this a little bit more
but through your engagement and
questioning of students with the class
you want them to get really key
definitions down for you as a teacher
you might be concerned about how do I
take this really rich content and pare
it down to the students level and this
is where some of the resources that you
have at your disposal
um come into play the first place that I
would recommend that teachers go to is
their
core knowledge teacher handbooks these
are in grades K through five and there
are definitions in the science sections
that are written at the grade level for
that student so you don't have to look
up something like the Golgi apparatus
and a high school biology textbook and
then pare that down to an elementary
grade level so the first go-to place
we're finding good definitions is that
core knowledge teacher handbook then
depending on your grade level your
students have textbooks and you have a
teachers edition that give you some
vocabulary again at their level in third
and fourth grade these are the Delta
science content readers and in fifth
through seventh grade and sometimes also
eighth grade the titles come from the
prentice hall science Explorer series
and then in eighth grade your school may
choose to use something like high school
physics book named conceptual physics
but these are your gear guides your go
to Zhaan what kind of vocabulary what
kind of concepts and models and theories
you should require the students to
emphasize again I just remind you that
these topics spiral upon themselves and
they're going to be hit on year after
year so just take a peek at which grade
levels are going to have these again and
take the pressure off of yourself that
you have to get them mastered completely
in your grade level you're laying these
really foundational blocks for
vocabulary and concepts that will be
repeated year after year the fourth
aspect of a really great science lesson
is incorporating the science biographies
this is a really exciting part of our
scope and sequence for science and I
think it's one that you'll really enjoy
we have incorporated anywhere from four
to six science scientists in each grade
level there are other schools that do
this but oftentimes the scientists are
taught at the very end of the school
year in their own unit what we have done
and what we recommend is putting the
scientist into the unit in which they
are relevant so that students can really
get this full story of that scientific
concept there's a human aspect that gets
pulled into it there's another story
that gets pulled into it and students
can really fully more fully understand
the process of science from a human
perspective and so the scientists are
listed in your in your scope and
sequence exactly where they should be
with the concepts that they have you
also have several resources in at your
disposal to teach these scientists and
this is an area where you should feel a
lot of freedom on how you want to teach
these scientists maybe you want to do a
read aloud and maybe you want to do a
couple of different read Aloud's with
your elementary students maybe you want
to give a little bit of a lecture and
then you want to model or recreate the
experiment that that scientists did at
more of an elementary level you could
spend one day on a scientist you could
spend a whole week on a scientist again
the resources that we'd recommend for
pulling information for these scientists
are the core knowledge teacher handbooks
what's your whatever greater third
grader fourth grader needs to know and
then we also have listed in the scope
and sequence several other resources
that you can use however you'd like for
the science biographies so again going
back to that that fifth grade example of
cells a couple of scientists that might
be talked about are people like Robert
Hooke who's the person who actually
coined the word cells and you could tell
the students the story of how he came up
with that word and that's because he
looked at a piece of cork from a white
bottle under a microscope or a little
slice of it under a microscope and saw
what he thought were little rooms or
cells of a religious organization or of
a prison and that's what he why he came
up with the word cells we now know that
cork is wood and comes from plants and
plant cells are more rigid and have that
more square like structure so you could
tell students that story through your
discussion or through a read aloud
the fifth principle is to require to
teach - and were to require really clear
and concise explanations of your
students and this can be done in writing
especially when they're older or even
just orally through your
question-and-answer flow in your class
especially with younger students so here
are a couple of examples of how this
might get scaffolded from fifth grade to
seventh grade to high school with the
same concept so the mitochondria
mitochondrion or multiple mitochondria
are really important parts of the cell
and often times students learn a
definition such as the mitochondrion is
the powerhouse of the cell well that's a
very basic definition and doesn't really
tell you exactly what the mitochondria
does so at a fifth grade and then even
seventh grade eggs example my a better
explanation might be something like the
mitochondria release energy from the
cell that's a short definition for
students but it also gives you a very
clear explanation of what the
mitochondria do when students get into
high school and they really have to
focus more on the mitochondria for
several different cellular processes
such as photosynthesis or respiration
then you might require something like
the mitochondria are the sites of
cellular respiration where the cell
breaks down small glucose molecules into
ATP that's the type of definition that
you'd find in a high school book but
isn't something that you want to require
of a fifth or sixth grade student the
sixth principle is to perform
demonstrations and labs or other
teacher-led activities that are going to
supplement your instruction we will be
talking more about these kind of
one-on-one and there are several
different examples of these on box our
file sharing system but just a couple of
different principles to keep in mind
when you're performing demonstrations
and labs first definitely don't think
that a classical education means that
you don't do hands-on activities we
definitely want the students to be doing
science one of the challenges or
recommendations that I have for a first
teacher is to try to do one lab demo
activity something that's not just the
students listening to you or engaging in
discussion just one per unit for most of
you that's five to seven in an entire
school year and you can definitely do
more but they do take preparation and
time and you have a lot of different
classes that you're preparing for but
getting yourself more comfortable with
doing science with your students will be
very beneficial and you'll find that the
students really can grasp the concepts
even more by engaging with the material
one of the resources that we have on box
that we recommend you read over is
called our projects in the classical
school or a project-based learning white
paper that goes into a little bit more
detail philosophically about what the
place is of projects in a school but
here are a couple again of examples in
anchored in something like parts of the
cell and maybe many of you have done
this yourself as a teacher had to do
this as a student or maybe even had to
do it with your own children but one
common example is to have students make
a cell model out of candy or other
materials and this can be very fun for
the kids but it takes a lot of time
usually at home and then students may or
may not fully understand why they picked
the materials that they did a good way
to do this is to have students complete
some sort of a model in which then they
have to explain why did they use the
materials that they did I might
recommend though that this is even
better if done with some class time
where teachers are able to help the
students put something together but
often times the typical example that you
will see is just some instruction sheet
being sent home and the parents have to
help this child put the model together
and then the students bring it in and it
just sits on the shelf so if you're if
you would like students to make a model
of anything in science you want to give
them clear instructions and have them
explain why they pick the substances
that they did to accurately reflect the
model that they're putting together
I would say maybe a better thing to do
is to have students actually engage with
cells and so you can view prepared
slides microscope slides that can be
very inexpensively ordered from a
biological company or just images of
electron micrographs so pictures from
under a microscope and have students
through question-and-answer with you
identify the organelles or even in pairs
and filling out a table in which they're
being scientists making observations and
identifying that's that organelle for
you and that can be done again with
images even if you don't have access to
microscopes as your school grows and is
able to obtain some more science
equipment especially as your school
expands into the upper grades we really
encourage schools to have those upper
grades share those materials with
elementary teachers so and to build
relationships across the faculty and
with the students so maybe some ninth
grade biology students can work with a
5th grade class on using the microscopes
maybe the 5th grade teacher
students get to go to the ninth grade
biology class and look at specimens
under a microscope it's very easy to do
things like make onion skin slides where
you just slice a very thin layer of an
onion and you don't even need that high
power of a microscope to be able to view
the onion cells under a microscope with
a lot of adult supervision and proper
hygienic practices you can swab on the
inside of a student's cheek and look at
skin cells under a microscope if you
have even a retention pond outside your
school just small drops of the pond
water will allow students to see algae
and other protists under a microscope
again and students can just identify the
organelles they might not even have to
write anything down but just being able
to see the organelles and explain their
process will help them fully understand
the material that you've already taught
them
finally my less principle is to ask
really excellent questions and we've
talked a little bit about this in in
some of the previous principles but
again using an example from from fifth
grade say you've taught all of the
organelles the students have the
definitions and their notes you've done
a lot of back and forth with them so
they've mastered the the organelles
they've seen some images and you want to
help make some connections from the
cellular level to the more macro the
animal or plant level so I might start
by asking the student what is the
function of a vacuole hopefully by
towards the end of the unit most of the
kids can tell me that a vacuole is the
storage unit of our storage organelle of
a plant cell oftentimes as holding water
and then I might seemingly seem like I'm
jumping to a different topic but asking
them well why do plants wilt and
students will probably know that plants
wilt because they are lacking water and
then I might ask well what is happening
with a plant so when leaves are wilting
or in other words what organelle is
affected and they might start to connect
that the vacuole doesn't have enough
water so what would happen to that
organelle to that vacuole when you water
the plant
well the vacuole is going to fill with
water it's going to expand and it's
going to push on that cell wall and
allow those leaves to perk up which is
what we see a couple of just ways that
you can ask really good questions of
your students in class and how you can
use those questions in different ways
you might use coral response so that
first question what is the job of a
vacuole that would be great for a coral
response and I know that coral response
is used a lot with your literacy and
orthography lessons but they can also be
used in other subject areas like science
they're really good for short
definitions for vocabulary words and for
names of people they help keep the whole
class together when they all have to
answer together and most of the time
this is used for elementary students but
I've oftentimes found
that with older students if you see that
they're drifting off a little bit or you
need to pull them all back together you
can do some choral response with them
and then kind of ease back off because
they they don't really like it very
often but it gets them back with you and
then you can move on into more of a
discussion style another way of asking
questions is through cold calling or
random calling one thing that this does
is kind of keep students on their toes
so nobody can hide in your class if they
know that they can be called on you at
any time but I would caution you that
you should first really get to know your
kids before you do this because you
don't want to just pick on a kid who you
know is probably going to maybe struggle
with the material a little bit so if you
went once you get to know your kids and
their abilities and their confidence in
your classroom you might save those kind
of easier questions such as what is a
vacuole for your quieter kids or your
strugglers where you can call on them
and they maybe didn't raise their hand
but they'll know the right answer and
they'll feel more confident and then you
can save those more application style
questions or those questions that
stretch kids for those stronger students
who you know can help kind of spur the
discussion and continue on the
conversation to a deeper level just a
couple little tidbits with this if you
have students who don't know the answer
you want to establish a culture in your
classroom of of it's okay to not know
the answer but that I don't know isn't
necessarily acceptable so when a student
doesn't know you can ask them some more
questions or help guide them to their
textbook or their book in order to find
the answer or maybe they're still just
struggling and so you go on to another
student to help them out but always come
back to that first student and give him
another chance or another question so
that everybody can be fully engaged in
the class that's all that I have for you
today about how to make a great science
lesson in your classroom and I am always
available for you to contact me with any
questions thank you